what's going on everybody I'm Warren
Thompson welcome back to the channel and
I'm sure most of you have been following
all of the news about Jeremy Renner who
plays Hawkeye of course over the past
couple of days if you haven't sadly he
was in a very tragic accident that put
him in the hospital where he had to have
two surgeries and is now in critical but
stable condition and we have a really
good update from Jeremy Renner himself
but also we now know what exactly
happened what exactly the accident was
and how he ended up being rushed to the
hospital so the doctors and nurses and
everybody could save his life and as it
turns out he's really just a real life
Avenger this accident came by him
helping other people and it actually is
quite heartwarming now this statement is
coming from Reno city mayor Hillary
shive who is actually close friends with
Jeremy Renner Reno is where Jeremy lives
at least part-time which is where he was
spending his new years and on New Year's
days when the incident happened and
here's what mayor Hillary shiv had to
say a about the accident and what
happened in an official statement she
said he was helping someone stranded in
the snow somebody got stuck in the snow
and Jeremy Renner was trying to help
also during a press conference yesterday
washu County Sheriff Dan balham gave us
even more details about what exactly
happened after using a piston Berry snow
groomer to tow one of his neighbor's
cars out of the snow he got out of the
Piston Berry and the Piston Berry
started to roll and in an effort to stop
it Jeremy attempted to climb back into
the driver's seat and at that point
sadly it ran him over this resulted in
his chest trauma and Orthopedic injuries
which caused him to have the surgeries
but based off of the reports the
surgeries went well and Jeremy is in
stable condition right now he even
released this post on Instagram
yesterday sharing a picture of himself
and just giving a quick update in the
caption stating thank you all for your
kind words I'm too messed up now to type
but I send love to you all as sad as it
is to see him beat up like this in real
life in it is really good to hear that
he's doing better and it's really nice
to know that he really does care about
his community and he was helping his
neighbors the mayor even went on record
stating that he is always helping people
so he truly is a Great Hero in real life
so we're sending our thoughts our
prayers our Positive Vibes all the love
towards him in a quick and speedy
recovery drop some kind words about
Jeremy Renner down below don't forget to
subscribe to stay up to date and we'll
catch you all in the next video woof
woof